good afternoon I gave up on waiting for
the next five 1500 people to come
apparently they're late
they miss the room in the wrong place
yes this is fast where the best course
at this hour right now friends thank you
for being here I'm very excited about
this presentation it's actually um
rather new material and there's a lot of
its own
I was kind of very anxious to start as
early as possible so we can so we can
talk I'm going to talk a bit about the
art of benchmarking I noticed there's a
lot of there's a lot of mistakes people
do when benchmarking code and I just
wanted to make a few quick points this
is not really like the meat of the of
this of this talk here but I think it's
important as an introduction so I'm sure
many of us have heard of our mouths law
it's used it's used usually in parallel
computing who can shout handles law
there's a guy in the litter in the last
row I assume he would say something like
if you have two components in a system
and one is 80% contributing to the time
spent in running the system and there is
20%
even though you improved the second
subsystem by 100% that's you know your
your gains are limited theoretically to
20% I would say it's the arm does I
would call this a different way I would
call it Captain Obvious as law right
it's an obvious law but it's amazing how
often people lose track of it and gonna
free simply forget the simple reality
that if you have a number you have a
number of processes that contribute to
to a computation definitely that so the
critical path is going to be where you
want to spend your time on optimizing
I've seen a lot of people dedicating
inordinate amounts of time speeding up
and I'm not kidding command line
processing this is not a joke and
there's been a discussion actually can
finally there's records of it online
what people are like oh this command
line processing I can make it faster
and it will take instead of two
microseconds it would be one microsecond
which is by the way it's a hundred
percent improvement right it's an
amazing percentage wise improvement but
of course it doesn't matter in the grand
scale of things so I don't think I need
to insist on the law of FanDuel so
whenever you want to optimize pretty
much anything it even in life if you
wish
you must measure right so you can you
know the classic dictum goes you can't
improve what you can't measure and
that's definitely the case with
performance I've seen a lot of people
spending time on improving things
without having a clear idea or where
they started from and or what was the
purpose of going the you know to a
faster code etc so I'm sure I don't need
to because those are bad people they are
not in this room present company is
awesome right we're doing great thank
you
so juice hot sauce from the whole
application there is our complementary
law lot mass law and a lot minds not an
Indian researcher is just under spell
deity the other way around just a
reverse right STD reverse right so this
is a less obvious law and it goes well
you gotta optimize hot as hot spots
outside the application and then plug it
back and measure again which is not
intuitive who can give us an perception
of why that would be
why would I advise people to do that
ideas thoughts so I want to make it
clear let's say I determine that a
particular algorithm is critical to the
runtime application I need to spend time
improving it so I say don't improve it
inside the application take it out into
a smaller benchmark improve it and then
plug it back measure again make sure the
improvements carried which is there's
kind of there's a story to that we're
gonna get to that and then be happy
right so why would I advise people to do
that
well yes please
my benchmark stimulus would need to so
that's a challenge more than my
benchmark input would need to simulate
what the application would do correct
but that would be a requirement for the
this whole process of yes Patricia you
want to remove noise exactly so a
central thing that happens in modern
computing is that there's a lot of noise
going on about and it's very often that
you have this 120 percent speed-up he
doesn't come as like you have an idea
and it improves the thing by 1/5 it
comes at 9 2% improvements why 9 and not
10 the math is not right is there is it
compounding thank you very much so they
compound so it's actually 2 to the power
of 1 point something a little and you
get to 20% by only 9 iterations in a 2
percent improvement cycle so very often
you want to take the algorithm from the
noisy environment in which it resides
and be able be able to crank 1% and be
able to measure that and be able to be
confident that that particular 1%
improvement is going to count and be
carried into the final application so
also there's a number of practicalities
associated with this the edit and
benchmark cycle is Sloane the whole
application so definitely you want to
have a quick iteration in measuring
performance so you don't need to so you
can you know have you can try many ideas
fast it's amazing how much friction that
how much how much friction can can
impede your way of thinking every all of
us know like slow compile times come on
right the slower compiler is the more
you your mental flow gets gets more
disturbed right but so this will be the
counter the counter effect here do not
forget that optimizations have global
effects there's cash effects these
memory allocations and deallocations
there will be branch predictor
hogging the billikin tension etc etc etc
so that's why after improve your thing
by 20% you gotta carry back in the
application and see what happened to
those two 20% right true story when work
at Facebook on the HHV M compiler which
compiles PHP code into a JIT and we
can't do that that is not possible to do
because the application is so hide it's
dominated by the global effects and the
main thing that the team had to fight
against was cache misses on the
instruction cache it turns out large
code was the main number one by a large
margin issue
so if think of this if your main problem
is I have to be code is the first step
you want to take all let's take the big
portion of the big code and make it
smaller measure that it's nonsensical
right doesn't make sense so therefore we
had to measure on the whole application
there's an entire team
I'm not kidding and tighten with
scientists and statisticians and stuff
dedicated to not optimizing that was a
different team I wasn't that there's
another different team dedicated with
being able to measure minut differences
in performance and the way it goes you
send like five hundred thousand pages
with the baseline the existing code you
send half a million pages with the new
supposedly improved code and you're
trying to find that deltas and you're
looking at you know looking at really
real all and the best we could get to
was one percent so if it was less than
one percent we will throw it away
because it was not demonstrably better
so huh those are the days so anyway so
I'm just saying that most of the time
you don't have that kind of problem but
sometimes you do right so a slide that
is not here because it's I shouldn't
mention this and you you're not play
victim of this
right York or some not even your
co-workers your former co-workers are
the bad people right I've seen time and
again you know it bears mentioning
people still measure the speed of debug
bills
you have no business measuring the speed
of a debug built it's like I spent once
one week because a co-worker kind of
said oh actually this thing is really
slow much slower than the baseline it's
why did we make that change
oh so we gotta look into this and find
out wait a second I was measuring the
debug build the debug builds that was
supposed to be fast so it's not there's
no purpose in in it being fast right so
you want to measure that there's a lot
of difference said you know people who
do different setups for baseline and
measured we buy me by which I mean the
following
for example consider this you have your
baseline which is the sort of the
existing algorithm an existing code then
you start the timer you do it and you
stop the timer right so we have that and
then right after that you start again
the timer and and that's your code and
stop the timer compare that to what's
the fellow mistake what is the fellow
mistake poor the heap thank you yes yeah
the ones you say the key words I mean I
know you I know I know what you up to so
the moment you said the key word I knew
you have the answer so essentially
consider this consider that the baseline
is going to allocate memory hello Camela
look new whatnot right allocates memory
and then it he allocates it so it looks
like everything went back to normal but
no it didn't go back to normal the heap
right now is in a completely different
state because much of what a good memory
allocator does is collect you know hold
onto memory that was allocated and then
be allocated and put it in neat data
structures that are ready for the next
fight right so they have that free lists
they have you know the all of that
you're not to mention the cache is warm
not to mention a variety of other
effects right
so we don't you know we you don't want
your former co-workers to do that kind
of stuff
agreed yes thank you
not to mention things like worth of cash
files databases DNS and all that stuff
if you do a lookup in in the base line
then it's going to be much faster the
second time you should not that
techniques on every operating system and
file system to essentially cool the file
cache how would you do it on Windows
restart the machine yeah that's gonna
work and that you know I absolutely try
would do that yes there is a technique
that somebody got don't use Windows but
I know there's a possibility to dismount
and remount drives in in Windows right
is there Paul
okay so my here here's the thing my hope
was that there's gonna be a person in
this room is gonna be yeah of course you
do XY and Z and that like you do what
that fine person said and now I'm kind
of lost because I don't I dunno how to
do it in Linux you mount and unmount the
filesystem you can what you can read
lots of other files where they'll be
slow right yeah actually that's that's
very - then you know absent any other
but in principle Linux uses all of the
i-news Ram as file buffers caches so and
a way to get rid of that is your mounted
drive so you're on mount jiri mount and
then it starts cold that's great okay
but still that's not the topic of today
which will get in don't worry we're
getting there
another pitfall that I saw your former
co-workers doing is they include
ancillary work in measurement probably
like statistically a bunch of
measurements measure like the speed of
printf right you know and all that kind
of stuff so you know of course this is
not something that any of us would ever
do I've seen also a procedural mistake
when I say procedurally not innocent a
procedural programming procedure by
means of like human procedure like way
of do
things a procedural mistake and what I
think is really distinguishing between
scientists and engineers the scientists
would be like you know like Sheldon in
that show right
so very very obsessively changing one
parameter at a time and measuring again
I've seen Pyrrha I change like 10 I had
10 ideas so I'm planning them all and
let me measure again and then we have no
idea which actually helped and which not
and maybe there's even two that cancel
each other right so you don't want that
to happen so you change one thing at a
time very rigorously and you proceed
like that not to mention optimize rare
cases and pesum eyes others the frequent
cases happy credit to Stack Overflow
which feature the following very
interesting discussion there's a
programmer saying why is sort slower
than is sorted on sorted arrays so the
experiment would be I sort an array I
run is sorted which checks whether it
returns a bool right and also I sort the
array and by some reasoning it would go
well sort should do absolutely nothing
if the result is already sorted so it
should have the exact speed of is sorted
and the solution envisioned by that fine
programmer was the first running sort
should be if is sorted returned I'm sure
she'd ironic right because that's gonna
work exactly once in a lifetime for it
just so happen I pass like an idiot and
already sorted array to sort and yes
that was fast
ladies and gentleman thank you very much
but actually it Pesa mised everybody
else because it makes an extra pass to
the array without actually doing
anything of interest all right
that's the example I meant to I'd the
guide should collect that graph which is
very nice of him so sort is slower than
is sorted yes that's true and is
expected
so today we're facing impossible odds in
optimizing our code today's computers
are very too complicated for our poor
minds I'm not kidding this is like
really a table a table point in history
to be out you know what I want to be I
want to be in like the 70s the days of
zilog z80 the 80s sorry the eighties
great music too so I want to be in the
80s and the the good days of the
eighties are at the zilog z80 the the
one of the first micro processors of any
success and back then it was there's no
pipelining you knew exactly how many
cycles hitting each instruction took you
had zero weight memory access friends
amazing you could get all the way to
memory and back fetch the data it all
happened in one cycle no cash no no no
all of that nonsense did not exist no
speculative execution of branch
prediction what's with all that crap man
you know none of that you could actually
quite literally read the program and see
oh this is gonna take 253 cycles to
execute you knew exactly what we're
getting right so well fast forward to
nowadays
Wow they got to a point where amazingly
we have like in trouble you can't
measure what you know it's impossible to
obtain the same measurement twice when
you measure speed right so you even have
things like dynamic frequency control
who knows about so yeah thank you so
whatever it measure you know whenever
you use the CPU runs it figures it's
idling so then it slows down which you
know as an aside is very very human
thing to do let's take a nap rights take
a little break so it ran some slow speed
and then when you kind of start again
and detects there's work to be done like
a loop that does things well let me
accelerate and all that stuff so it's
virtually impossible nowadays to get
identical timings for the same
experiment and by the way this was very
it's a marketing thing there's a
consistent trend since the 80s to trade
reproducible performance for average
speed and not everybody did so so this
was this was a marketing source
essentially it was like that people use
desktop applications there is Excel and
we want people to essentially perceive
that on average the computer is fast
however there are some applications in
which you do one reproducible
performance and create a supercomputer
company they did have such a clientele
and Cray had no cash for many years I'm
not sure if like given today they gave
up but they had no cash they had like
all it was all deterministic right so
craze not is not the sort of a Titan of
computing nowadays so in a way average
performance one so one great thing that
should not help you is intuition silicon
is not intuitive it's it's very
difficult for a human being to travel
develop a good intuition of how a CPA is
gonna he's gonna run so we make almost
without without mistake we make narrow
obsolete wrong assumptions for example a
common dictum is for your instruction
means faster code is that room who's
with me
fewer instructions are faster code yes
one instruction what if that instruction
is fetching from memory sorry
you get to pick the instruction how
that's cheating okay you win okay so
definitely that's something that's more
subtle than that but that's actually
definitely not always fair few
instruction means faster code but
there's also a proxy phenomenon by on
average if you get to reduce the number
of instructions you're gonna there's
only this much you can you can go
without actually accelerating the code
so it's a good proxy to look at but it's
not definitely an immutable truth so
that doesn't go how about that is faster
than computation caching memorization
the nice things right of course I don't
need to pause and ask people and stop
because you know very well that
sometimes the data actually it's too
much just too much of it and this cache
effect so data is not faster than
computation some computation but not all
is faster than data
barato right so you gotta find the right
balance and there's one good intuition
you can have which is I should sit down
and time this stuff that's the best
that's not one intuition you can use
it's been many very many times I I do
this for a living it's been very very
many times I've I've been like ah let me
measure this crazy stupid idea that I'm
sure is gonna be terrible and it went
well
advise of most of the time it was
vice-versa let me try this awesome idea
which I have and it just works and it's
amazing and it's fast and it was just
four times slower it's a it's actually
it just keeps on happening it's like my
Donuts karma maybe I've done something
really bad in a previous life so
measuring is gonna give up on leg leg up
on experts who are too smart to measure
that's a classic code so that said there
are a number of heuristics you can rely
on
and when I say heuristics I mean things
to look at without blindly following
them or believing them they are proxies
they're heuristics they're
for example math is your most important
airline optimization we are past the day
when we would do things like
self-modifying code that would you know
write a bit here and a bit there an
assembler and machine code I think we'll
pass that age I think we're in in the
age of math think you the virtue like
all optimizations of interest nowadays
are motivated by mathematics and by
mathematics I mean the following you
don't transformation the code that you
know is going to make the code faster
and use math to prove to yourself and
others that the transformation preserves
the semantics of the code right also you
can use things like mathematical
identities yes because math doesn't care
about expenses math is like yeah you
know I'm gonna do a super factorial no
problem I can prove things about it and
math doesn't care about how much is
spent computing things things as long as
it gets the proof right so math doesn't
say what's interesting and what's not
and what's cheap and what's not mad that
does tell you only what's there and
what's not what's true and what's not so
that's how you use it I think we're also
kind of moving a bit away from a variety
of mini tricks that people is an
optimization we're moving again to
towards the more principled approach I'm
talking about the last maybe five maybe
ten years there's been a sort of a trend
another heuristic that we can use is
that computers like boring and they
don't like surprises
computers like boring the best funk the
best thing to optimize for a compiler is
a main function that's a million lines
and it has no branching no if and oils
and no nothing that don't write code
like that but you know this is like this
would be like ideal because just
straight line code it just goes and goes
and goes and all the compiles to do is
fetch the next instruction execute it
and retire it and the the the CP is very
good at that kind of stuff so they hate
surprises which come into a form of
branching you don't know where you're
gonna go right
Dependencies I have I need to do this
first and the second and by the time you
know it I can't do anything here without
finishing this right so in a way this
guy is surprised by the result of this
operation right indirect calls are the
worst we've been talking with a couple
of colleagues like no matter what no
matter how good cpu is get a pointer to
a function is gonna ruin their day you
have a pointer to a function you're
having a good time there and as soon as
the pointer of function comes into place
like oh my goodness this is so slow like
they can't they I'm not sure why they
can't figure out a way to make that like
a hundred times faster because it is
real slow right
I was kidding it's a hard problem right
so the thing is again it's a surprise
because you don't know what function
you're calling you know this kind of
stuff algorithm I'm gonna for myself
we're a bit in a hurry because there's
there's so much material but I'm gonna
afford myself a minute to tell you a
story that I think it has it has meaning
I was so I had a paper on median finding
and I was talking to a researcher about
an improved sort algorithm and part of
that improves old algorithm would be the
insertion sort part which is the endgame
of quicksort right quicksort is not very
good for small inputs like you're like
50 items or 30 items or 20 items
definitely don't want to use quicksort
anymore you want to switch to a to an
algorithm that is bankrupt B go in a
bigger way however when the numbers are
small is you know 20 times 19 is not too
bad right meaning like 20 squared right
so the end game for quicksort would be
insertion sort which goes the following
way it goes you start from the from the
left so again imagine like 20 numbers so
it start from the left and you're going
to build a sorted array by inserting
from the you know the unsorted portion
into the sorted array and that's your
insertion sort and it takes its
quadratic and every time you're going to
do the next insertion you're going to
have to search the value to insert into
they're already sorted array make sense
and they're gonna move you're gonna move
the rest right insert a and move the
rest right understood this algorithm is
pretty well known even though you didn't
write it in awhile of course I didn't
write it either in years but you know I
remember from the drunken days of
college I do remember you know I kind of
I'm fluent with it right and we will we
are so now insertion sort
so this which researcher implements an
insertion sort that does the following
whenever it needs to insert the next
value it starts from the end of the
already sorted array in searches for
linearly and then finds the insertion
point inserts move moves on right but
then so clever
I said you mister are not getting it
you do need to the binary search binary
search is gonna go in the middle of the
already sorted portion and it's going to
do dramatically fewer comparisons
because it binary search log and instead
of linear right
yes which algorithm was four times
smaller slower yes mine the binary
search was not only a bit so slower not
only depending on things slower it was
unambiguously unequivocally way slower
than the naive I'm gonna do a linear
search from the back of the inserted
array my question to you in the
challenge he took us days to figure out
why so I'm gonna give you 30 seconds why
do you think that yes you don't get any
prefetching no they were talking small
arrays it was really there's no cash
issues branching what about branching
excellent thank you so the answer was
it's the brand it's the is the surprise
that comes with branching consider this
when you do a loop that goes from the
end from the end of the sorted portion
and does a linear search how many times
do you fail to predict you may fail at
the beginning the first comparison you
may fail to predict it because you have
no idea what state you're in so in the
worst case you're gonna fail once and
then you go and you're gonna go you
succeed at predicting that it's gonna
keep going
you succeed at predicting because the
predictor works whenever you succeed to
do something you assuming it's gonna go
again just as fine so it assumes it goes
well so the loop is gonna go with good
prediction until the found portion which
is the second fail of predicting there's
two failures to predict however when you
do binary search every search is
interested every every test is
interesting and surprising because
depending on a t-girl
left or you go right so it's not like
it's not boring so you may fail and you
are gonna fail by you can prove very
clearly that you're gonna fail multiple
times to predict the next comparison
because it goes all over the place right
so that's kind of an interesting lesson
whereby not only I used an algorithm
that was theoretically faster it
provably did I measure Dom of
comparisons it was dramatically smaller
however the realities of hardware
settled in and changed the outcome was
it's an interesting process is to spend
time on I think it's gonna instructive
kind of thing you notes okay so
computers like boring they don't like
surprises that was the top point
indirect rights are slow strengths hurts
when I say strengths I mean difficult
operations right division hurts more
than multiplication multiplication has
more than addition etc
smallest beautiful small cow small Dara
is beautiful though that may change
there's been I've read a few articles
about this already so there is the
advent of some new kind of memory types
which are so fast that you need four
CPUs to drive them and they are used
currently in very specialized
applications but if those become
mainstream we may not have a memory
hierarchy issue anymore so that may
change in the future gonna have memory
that's so fast you actually can saturate
it so that was the that's the sort of
the most recent development I know about
cool but before that don't forget
whenever a benchmark keep the following
in mind the goal is to estimate the
speed of some algorithm and the usual
procedure is choose experimental
conditions run experiment multiple times
and then take the average and by the
time I am done reading the slide I have
made a fatal mistake which you will tell
me about leave you a victor sorry you
need a baseline I assume we have a
baseline you're not allowed to questions
I'm I'm like from here so okay go ahead
Victor the average is wrong why is it
wrong
outliers are going to affect it he just
turns out that noise in computers is
weird in several ways but one is first
of all it's always additive so there's
no noise in a computer that makes things
run faster than they click could if you
know away you're a billionaire right you
could make money off of that it's like
ah there's like this crazy network
activity in my computer and then that
faster it's amazing what's called try
pattern this right so all noise is
additive so it doesn't look like a
Gaussian like most people like model
noises or it must be a Gaussian all of
them no it's actually half a Gaussian
it's actually a kind of a different
distribution possum but you know
essentially it's like it's it's a half a
curve and the second thing
when noise comes it's humongous
like we're talking here's the thing
imagine I stop talking right now I go
get a burrito eat a burrito have some
coffee as well and come back and tell my
talk that's us sorry for the
interruption
right so it's this long that actually
whenever I have for example a time I
interrupt that's going to you know do a
system call to advance the clock and the
time zone nonsense all that stuff that's
happening on your computer on a regular
basis and if it just so happens it
interrupts your test that wants to
figure out how fast is an addition of
two floating point numbers you see what
I'm saying on average when Bill Gates
hopes hops on a bus in Seattle everybody
on the bus is going to be a super
billionaire right on average so the
outline outliers are so punishing we're
talking many orders of magnitude in
considering them is going to profoundly
alter measurements so I'm not gonna
insist on this but please averages I've
taken the averages about the last that
the worst thing you can do in when
measuring speed what do you want to take
them mean other thoughts ideas here's a
piece of thought how about you take
whatever you measure the most samples
the most density so the more you know
you have experiments and some numbers
appear more often than others so maybe
you take that it's called a mode of the
distribution the mode is great what are
the ideas median mean median right
minimum minimum is actually an
interesting idea
most of my experiments take the minimum
because the mail means the least noisy
result you ever get and if you optimize
for the minimum definitely gonna get a
better average right so anyway all right
now we discussed this we discussed that
we discussed that right so if not
average we discussed more
we discussed actually I did some
measurements myself and it turns out
that whenever I take the mode if you
measure many times the mode tends to go
to the minimum right so slowly the mode
that the maximum density of samples goes
to the minimum because if you measure
very many times the noise is gonna get
cancelled because it's all over the
place so you're gonna get a mode that's
very close to the minimum however
there's a class of algorithm that
doesn't work with the minimum at all
randomized algorithms who can give us an
example of a randomized algorithms
example of a randomized algorithm yes
please
Monte Carlo simulation in which you
randomly change the yes thank you great
something more like humane no more than
a humane sorry more more more like you
know because not everybody is gonna run
Monte Carlo simulations but there is one
like sort thank you
sort it primarily t-test so randomly I
didn't know that but yeah some sounds
completely now there's algorithms for
for example the travelling salesman
because airlines need to do that and the
travelling salesman is np-complete so
you can't really sit down and do it but
there is a randomized algorithm that is
guaranteed to give you in the worst case
twice the optimal solution tries the
cost of optimal so it's pretty a good
result a pretty good result but sort is
like a very simple example of of
randomized algorithm there's like a lot
of networking protocols use
randomization they use exponential
back-off and whatnot so there's there's
a lot of random elements in in
networking and you don't want to take
for those that minimum because consider
sorting when it's sort of quicksort and
you take the pivot and you take it at
random which is a good technique
actually some lab libraries do that you
sort many times and are you do you want
to pick up the lottery winner right it's
not a good idea to pick out like the the
most lucky case he
just got the people to straight down the
middle like five times in a row right so
that's like a very rare case in fact I
don't want to pick up that case as you
represent a representative run time of
the sort algorithm right so for those
you gotta go with things like I want to
throw away the largest 5% times and
actually if you plot the histogram of
times and frequencies you're going to
see that there's gonna be a few outliers
and it's gonna be very visible where the
the weird noise is and just cut that
away it's gonna be in the few percent
the top few percent average over the
last or trace thresholds a lot P 95 so
in networking in particular is very
interesting to take things like 95
percent of our you know our measurements
were below this time right that's P 95
and that's very nice for networking when
you want to make sure that your site
works properly across a number of
countries for example rate okay with
this the talk starts we're staying right
now so by the way you're in the fast
word talk this is it
I'm sure okay nobody's leaving great so
the first tip I'm going to give which is
concrete gonna have code so so far which
is just vague but we're gonna have code
so tip number one replace branches with
arithmetic and the idea is instead of a
branch you want to integrate the result
of the branch as a zero or one value so
that means essentially you you do the
test and you initialize an int with the
result of the test instead of doing if
on it you initialize an int with it and
then you use the in teen computation and
that int is going to be zero one right
so that means there's less pressure on
the branch predictor
there's no branching so there's no need
to to the branch prediction does let's
fail speculation there's no there's just
straight line code in those few stalls
so let's do a statistical task here as
an example sort the minimums of four to
the first quartile of an array
so we want we have an array and the
first 25% of the array should contain
each element should be the minimum four
elements of the entire array that's an
important step in in doing things like
approximate median median and stuff so
what I have here is to the to the jury
of some of your programs for c-sharp
programs I chose to use C sharp eyes as
an example C pluses people are going to
definitely figure out the code but since
this is a mainly official count how many
of you actually see char programmers
okay separate my predictor was right how
many you have no idea about C sharpen
hate myself for doing this okay
no-nobody I put an end in there so
that's difficult to answer okay so using
C sharp as a back end language I'm going
to take the minimum for given an array
of doubles I'm going to fetch the length
and then use for induction variables
which are going to go from 0 and by 4
and by 2 and 3 and by 4 ijkl and then
I'm going to do a loop that's going to
simply deposit the minimum in the
leftmost position and how many branches
do we have inside the loop let's take a
look we have an F here and we have an if
here so that would be two branches out 3
1 2 3 right great so that you know it
takes 3 it takes 3 tests to figure out
the meaning of four numbers and now a
word about how you test the speed of
such an algorithm you must test on some
you know because actually at this point
was was made in the beginning which was
your test data must be representative of
the actually input and what I did was to
test on the following five inputs organ
pipe is a data set that goes up and then
down
it's an artificial data set that does
this just to make sure I'm not
optimizing
for like already sort of the race or
something the second is simply random
data uniformly distributed the third
test is more interesting it's random
zero one data it's random it's random
zeros and ones so that you know even
though they're floating point numbers is
just zeros or ones the idea here been
behind a random zero one is that I want
to test data with a lot of duplicates
but at the same time it's unpredictable
right there's plenty of duplicates
because half are gonna be zeros half of
gonna be one but I have no idea what
they are so this is a great test for the
branch predict migrate amines branch
predict are happy then random Geron is
gonna miss mess it up right is going to
destroy it
I'm also cause I'm measuring sorted data
and I'm also finally going to test on
against real data and what I measure
here was word frequencies in the English
language as per Google there's a dataset
from Google so I just collected you know
essentially like billions of pages and I
got the word frequencies in English and
that's a real you know that's a real
data set that has data base some some
natural statistics and I test it on that
so you want a test on everything there
is right and this is a good don't forget
if you don't you see what I'm saying is
that if you for example if you test on
your two of these you get the
information you got a test on everything
so okay part one I'm gonna make a few
passes and kind of mimicking my my mind
as was doing this so first of like let's
do some Sense and Sensibility one thing
would be I want to they're gone one
would be I'm going to store this P dot
length in by foreigner variable so I
don't compute multiple times I'm doing
some manual common sub-expression
elimination if you wish so I'm going to
go for int I equals zero J gets and by
four and by two three and by four and
I'm going to say for I less than Q so
the Q limit is pre computed and then I
increment everything and I do the rest
it turns out the speed is the same but
indeed I convinced the
pilot to use less space it's good by the
way these results are reproducing on the
c-plus was back end as well so
everything I say about any comment I
make about the speed and speed
improvement applies to the C++ back-end
it's not only c-sharp so small same
speed smaller space awesome so it's a
good step just apply Sense and
Sensibility don't complete the same
thing many times don't do redundant work
that kind of stuff right motherhood and
apple pie pass to reduce dependencies so
I need to take the minimum of four items
so how about this I'm going to you to
first compute P of V versus P of J and
in a different branch P of K with P of L
so I'm going to compute the index here
and then I'm going to do the final test
here the idea being that the two
comparisons are not depending on each
other they're like two different four
distinct numbers and compare them two by
two and these comparisons are not
dependent on you upon each other so they
run in parallel or so I wished they
didn't so it turns out I got the same
speed this is one of those things you
got a measure because you don't know
exactly what's gonna happen so you get a
same speed
fine pass number three I'm going to try
to reduce the induction variables so
there's too many eyes Jay's case and
else being incremented there so let me
just use I and look at my for loop it
got dramatically simpler so I have y
equals four I less than Q which is a
quarter of the array and I just
increment I and inside the loop by trade
computation for Dara by means of for
example I compute here I plus three
times Q which would be you know the you
know one third of the array away from
here right so instead of having four in
four variables going in lockstep like
that I'm going to have one and compute
the rest every time in the envelope so
it looks like a reasonable thing to do
it didn't improve any speed right so
again I'm showing you this to show you
just how many ordeals I
through this was an important topic by
this I'd really had to do that fast so
let's take a look at the next attempt
pass number four this is actually simple
get rid of the multiplication by 3
because it's unnatural let me go back
one slide so here we have a
multiplication by 3 and it turns out
multiplying something by 3 is more
expensive than multiplying by 2 or not
multiplying at all right so let me
eliminate that multiplication so I pre
computed here QQ trees Q plus Q and then
I replace the multiplication by 3 with
the addition in Kuta Q 2 plus Q so that
actually made finally it moved the
needle so I got a 3% improvement and
that night I slept very happily but yes
with the compiler
move the common sub-expression times it
does sometimes it doesn't so that that's
that's a problem you know so the
compiler has only this much resources to
keep track on try different things and
stuff so it doesn't really try
everything
it should I agree
but actually that the meat is something
3% is nothing and for this algorithm we
got we've got a look like a fifth at
least right so let's try something more
radical how about this if only there
were a way to optionally add a value so
here let me define this function
optional that takes a flag and the value
and here's how it works the flag is 0
then optional returns 0 if flag is not 1
then it returns that value it's quite
literally an optional value C++ programs
please replace mentally discomfort
during 32 it's a cast
it's actually an implicit conversion to
in just put in here it's a minus int of
flag and value
this function quite literally took me a
lifetime to write because it's the sort
of it's a it's an integral of a number
of meaning in size that I had over years
and it's like actually I could I could
do this simple arithmetic that's gonna
work here's how it works
if flag is zero minus zero is zero and
zero and anything is zero so I'm done it
right returns zero so far so good
if flag is one then taking it to an int
is the integer one but taking minus of
that is what yes sorry right
it's a remarkable number it's all ones
in binary and it's going to become a
mass that when you add that thing with
anything is gonna you're gonna get that
thing right so I got a magic device and
you know about pretty confident I'm
gonna I'm gonna give this talk until
some compiler writer is gonna is gonna
be in it and at that point that guy is
gonna be out we got to do this in the
compiler right nobody does it right now
so I got this little function yes please
what if the flag is not zero neither
zero nor one I I don't handle that yeah
it I didn't know it's not guaranteed in
C in C I knew the C sharp has a there's
a discussion but in C++ is there such a
case
yeah but actually int int of boolean
true is one when when it again replace
this with end of flag and that's true
that's one that's the integer one so I'm
fairly confident that this this is
correct even in the most obscene
implementations of C++ today's
implementation really
at one bit so okay great so yes
sorry the I didn't work with the digital
multi-process compiler oh yeah that you
know D compiler has like the GCC and LD
see back and them both they both work
well with this so yeah so it doesn't
matter which source languages to some
extent but essentially was as soon as it
gets the logic the logic down
efficiently it's just gonna work so now
we have this a mini function which is
kind of a static in line in C++ function
and you could make it work with unsigned
and whatever so the idea is the same so
then we have how about this so we're
gonna go let's use it
we're gonna go M 0 equals I minus
optional of this guy right depending on
the condition so this is not a branch
any longer and again this is not a
branch any longer so I only have one
branch left so let's measure this guy
and here's where it gets really
interesting you get a 16% loss on organ
pipe you get an 18% loss on sorted so
friends if that were the only data it
tested on you'd move on right you see my
point you want to measure on different
data shapes however is 23 percent faster
random 0 1 and by that one I was like ah
there's something interesting here and
it's over two times faster than random
and no real data which is the most
interesting stuff where we want to work
on so this is a huge win and my question
to you is why did I get a loss in
performance on an organ pipe why did I
get a loss on sorted why did I get a
huge win on random there are no real
data yes please
there's no there's no difference in in
lining optional gets in lined yeah
yes huh when it's sorted the branch
predictor is gonna have a good day and
with organ pipe it's gonna have a good
day except for one hiccup in the middle
it's gonna have like one bad prediction
at the beginning one bed in the middle
one bed at the end that's three for the
huge array so awesome so for the cases
where the branch predictor is having an
easy unsurprised job it's just gonna do
faster than optional because action is
extra logic it does extra logical
operations and extra little things and
masks and whatnot however whenever he
moved to surprising data such as random
zero one random and real data then the
branch predictor is going to be swamped
is not going to be able to predict
things correctly and is going to lose to
our approach but wait there's more we
could actually use optional again so I
have just a few a little more original
take here nothing complicated I don't
expect you to like dropped all the
details of the code but if you see down
on it you can it can eliminate the last
branch to so you use optional everywhere
and there's no more branching zero
branch inside the loop however I noticed
it's still good but it's not as good as
the previous version and guess why so at
this point when you have two pieces of
code that are you know stamping you you
guys have to look at the generated code
you go to God bolt you does this
assemblies for AB for C sharp you can
you know essentially go and look at the
source look right and guess what I saw
in the disassembly I saw that the
compiler was smart enough to eliminate
this branch itself so the compiler
transform this into a conditional move
so it was already doing the last step he
said you know Andre you've done all this
work I'll help you here
alright so yes that's what happened
so essentially it's good to actually
look at the the end result of your of
your compilation process to figure out
exactly what happens and what was
happening was indeed the compiler was
doing a part of the work it was lifting
part of the way for me great there is
actually another thing I tried which was
not very successful but I think it will
be successful in other cases you can
write a little function that's also in
line which is if-else and you have a
boolean flag and you have an integer
which will be returning the flag is true
and you have another integer v2 which
you return if the flag is false and
let's see how it works we look at the
first line here is the same right yes
let's look at the second line and
converting the flag to an int which is
like really into flag and I'm taking
ain't of flag minus 1 and v2 so let's
see how this works if flag is 0 the
first line here is going to take 0 minus
0 the first this whole thing average to
0 right but the second thing goes from
in to 0 0 minus 1 is write minus 1 dot
and at with which is gonna give you V 2
so you get the second value if the flag
is 1 the the first line works just like
before and the second line is going to
be 1 minus 1 0 and you're done
right and it didn't work well on this
particular algorithm but I'm pretty sure
that if you paste this in your code if
the C files and you try it you're gonna
find situations in which it it does save
the day
awesome so I've been trying this and if
else didn't help here and again it's
because the compiler was already at work
replacing that test with the conditional
move cool
since we we have we are in we have just
two minutes left I'm going to stop here
and I'm going to this is I'm not sure
why this okay
so we're gonna stop here and I'm going
to take a few questions if you have yes
please a framework that captures the
real data yeah so but it's more like you
know opportunistically you just you know
you have your files you have your data
have your inputs so there's nothing
formalized about about the the
pre-processing part yes
questions yes please oh yeah so profiles
are a big part of optimization so you
know as we discussed in the opening you
gotta know what you think you know you
get a get a measure as the first step
and profilers are a huge tool especially
for subtle things such as cash spills
and you know all of that
the my dad has too big or my code is too
big and these things are very easy to
understand without a profiler so
definitely I would recommend actually
Intel was very nice they called me and
they gave me a free cap your vtune so I
should kind of pay them some lip service
here Wheaton is a great product right
sorry it is yeah so you know I'm feeling
good and I'm not really holding myself
here you know yes cash simulation that
is very slow actually so what I've what
I've done way in the in the days on my
grad school it was you could do that
kind of stuff on a much less powerful
machine right so you can do like I have
a very very weak machine and I'm doing
simulation on it to figure out cache
effects and stuff but you know profiles
are gonna show you these cache effects
quite nicely alright yes please
strength reduction so let me kind of
explain to everybody strength reduction
is a compiler optimization if you google
for it you're gonna find actually a few
pages written by compiler writers and
strength deduction is you take an
expression and you try to express the
same expression with cheaper operators
like you replace division with
multiplication and you replace
multiplication with addition and you
replace with shifts and you know for
example there is a there is a well-known
paper that allows you to replace
division by constant with a
multiplication by another constant and a
shift and everybody does that now
and that would be an example strength
reduction but that's it there is
strength reduction that how should I put
it that you can use creatively in ways
that compiles can't figure it out figure
out to rewrite algorithms with less
strong operations and I have a talk
about that if you google for my name a
faster you're going to find a talk of
mine last year which discusses the
exactly strength reduction all right I'm
hearing that the other people are done
so go get some food and coffee thank you
very much for being here
you're being great awesome thank you